la famine en ouganda émotions générale
l'aide se développe la prostitution en
accusation réquisitoire sévère à
grenoble tour de france hinault prête le
maillot jaune à knetemann madame
monsieur bonsoir la bombe à neutrons
était à l'étude depuis 1976 et sa
construction série pourrait commencer
dès 1990 dans le même temps la france
pourrait cette année décidé de s'équiper
de missile stratégique nucléaire mobile
ce sont les deux révélations
la conférence de presse de monsieur
giscard d'estaing hier dont le point
fort a été les problèmes de défense
ces deux projets nous sont détaillés
maintenant pas georges le père
un missile mobile stratégique c'est cela
un afflux de chars avec une fusée dessus
nous sommes ici quelque part en union
soviétique cette armada de missiles
mobiles s'entraîne à manoeuvrer sur un
terrain non préparé la toundra
sibérienne où les forêts de l'allemagne
de l'est
difficilement détectables ces missiles
stratégiques en cas de besoin peuvent
s'arrêter quasiment n'importe où se
mettre en position et tirer l'équivalent
français c'est le missile stratégique du
plateau d'albion mais celui ci baptisé
ssb est ce n'est pas mobile
il doit être lancé depuis un silo fixés
au sol pour le placer dans ce silo
l'armée emploie de gigantesques camion
pas question de tirer un missile de 15
mètres de long pesant 30 tonnes depuis
un affût mobile en revanche avec la
miniaturisation on sait faire
aujourd'hui en france des missiles
stratégiques de 7 m ne pesant que six
tonnes déjà de tels missiles existe ce
sont les m4 de sous marins nucléaires
mais va-t-on misé toute notre stratégie
sur cette seule force océanique ou
encore va-t-on vers une solution
terrestre comme celle du pluton petites
fusées tactique ne dépassant pas 120 km
de portée mais quand même nucléaire il
reste qu une troisième solution celle
que les américains commencent à
expérimenter le largage par avion comme
ce missile de croisière larguées depuis
un b 52 alors aurons nous bientôt en
france des missiles de croisière volante
au ras du sol pratiquement indétectable
par les radars ennemis capable d'une
précision effrayante ou à l'opposé nos
avions un transall par exemple vont-ils
larguer des gros missiles plus classique
mais tirer n'importe où dans le ciel
donc invulnérable décision en principe à
la fin de cette année
de même la décision de lancer la
fabrication de la bombe à neutrons n'est
pas encore prise cette bombe en
explosant à une certaine altitude tenue
secrète cause très peu de dégâts par
souffler chaleur sur l'objectif
militaire
mais ces radiations les neutrons
renforcée par un dispositif lui aussi
secret tu toute vie dans un cercle
restreint épargnant les civils des
villes voisines
rappelons quand même que toutes ces
bombes ne sont censés jamais servir si
ce n'est à dissuader l'ennemi de nous
attaquer oui alors tout le problème est
donc de savoir maintenant si en se
dotant de ce nouveau missile stratégique
mobile la france ne va pas changer de
stratégie nucléaire
l'armée française continuera-t-elle
d'attendre les attaques ennemies sur son
territoire ou portera-t-elle la bataille
hors de nos frontières
c'est la question que paul nahon imposé
à monsieur alexandre sanguinetti qui
répond à double titre celui de
spécialistes militaires et de gaulliste
désormais c'est tout l'espace
géographique européen qui fait fonction
de mots qui fait partie de nos intérêts
vitaux y compris les voies d'accès les
routes maritimes d'aériennes les points
de passage obligé qui permettent à
l'europe de vivre qui en sont les
poumons puisque c'est par là que nous
importons et par là que nous exportons
la notion de sanctuaire national est une
notion neutraliste est dépassé
complètement dépassés pour une raison
simple c'est que nous n'avons pas les
dimensions et les ressources pour être
un sanctuaire
par contre nous avons la notion
d'intérêt vital à partir duquel même en
zone périphérique ou en théâtre
d'opérations extérieures
nous pourrions être amenés à intervenir
toutes forces réunies avec l'armé
nucléaire
avec ou sans larmes nucléaire suivant
les circonstances
parce qu'il ne faut jamais sombrer dans
le dogmatisme
alors dans ce débat qu'est ce qui a
changé par l'introduction de la bombe à
neutrons ou savait pas grand chose c'est
un moyen qui s'ajoute que je rappelle
qu'en 66 ans - moyens plus modernes
certainement mais qui n'est lui même
qu'une et à la technique ne s'arrête
jamais l'évolution des armements ne
s'arrête
mais on ne peut jamais dire à un moment
donné de l'histoire
je suis arrivé au dernier point et plus
rien ne se produira et l'arme nucléaire
larmes me and hum tronic nous
permettrait par exemple d'intervenir je
le répète en zone périphérique ou un
théâtre d'opérations extérieures et
surtout de justifier le rapport coût
efficacité d'un certain nombre de
matériels pour protéger l'allemagne par
exemple mais ce n'est pas protégé
l'allemagne l'allemagne c'est désormais
simplement notre bastion c'est la
défense européenne c'est la défense de
l'europe de l'europe péninsulaire
étroite peu profondes et qui n'a pas
l'espace de manoeuvre et vous pensez que
la france veut assurer la défense de
l'allemagne là la france veut assurer sa
propre défense et sa propre défense de
commence pas au pont de kehl
ça commence où ça commence le plus loin
possible et ça c'est en réalité à
l'ensemble de la planète
il va falloir que les français
comprennent que depuis cinq ans nous
sommes entrés dans l'ère planétaire du
monde se sent qu'il est et j'aimerais
vous demander si les choix d'hier du
président de la république sont en
contradiction avec la doctrine du
général de gaulle en matière nucléaire
de stratégie nucléaire
je ne le crois pas je ne suis pas
porteur d'un morceau de la vraie croix
n'est dépositaire des tables de la loi
mais comme personne ne peut me dire ce
que dirait aujourd'hui le général j'ai
le sentiment que c'est dans la droite et
j'ajoute j'ajoute que le général
lui-même mettait en garde les militaires
dans un de ses ouvrages contre le
dogmatisme l'a priori sme et la façon de
considérer d'une façon absolue les
problèmes militaires
tout est toujours relatif ne reviendrait
pas sur les réactions à la conférence de
presse du président de république ne
l'ont fait dès hier soir et au cours
d'antenne de midi quelques réactions
tout de même sur ces problèmes de
défense mais à l'étranger
l'agent soviétique tu as ne fait pas de
commentaire mais être mais tout même
indirectement en garde les pays l'otan
contre l'installation de bornes en outre
on sur leur territoire au siège de
l'otan justement on est satisfait des
propos tenus par monsieur giscard
d'estaing commentaires du secrétaire de
l'alliance atlantique monsieur joseph
lotz je le cite ça ne va pas rendre la
france populaire
ce coup par contre tous ses alliés et en
particulier les américains d'après
monsieur loot ne peuvent que se réjouir
pas de commentaire à bonn ni à londres
enfin washington un porte parole du
gouvernement a déclaré que l' annonce
faite par le président giscard d'estaing
n'avait pas surpris les dirigeants
américains parmi les questions de
politique étrangère posée hier au
président de la république une concerne
l ouganda elle était posée par l'un de
nos confrères de la croix auquel le
président a fait parvenir une lettre
aujourd'hui dans laquelle il indique que
la france va envoyer plus de 20 mille
tonnes de céréales dans ce pays avant de
prendre une initiative politique
cette aide humanitaire est également
réclamée par le parti communiste
français
l'expédition est l'acheminement des
secours dans les pays en difficulté
comme l'ouganda nous l'avons vu l'autre
soir dans notre émission spéciale pose
d'énormes problèmes
comment une organisation comme l'unicef
par exemple est préparée à répondre à
ses demandes
gérard in et s'est rendu à copenhague à
genève où justement l'unicef possède un
centre de premiers secours
d'où sont acheminés nourriture et
matériel genève siège européen de
l'unicef c'est ici que sont prises les
décisions d'achat et d'envoi des secours
dites moi j'ai un petit problème là on a
une urgence pour le grand var j'aimerais
avoir trois groupes électrogènes 4 k
ways h à une équipe de sept
fonctionnaires travaillent par appels
d'offres internationaux
le financement provient des
contributions des gouvernements des dons
privés et des quêtes publiques
transporter le port de copenhague
c'est là sur un cake unicef installé
l'unique centre en europe de stockage et
d'emballage de marchandises de première
urgence dans ces hangars grand comme
trois terrains de football sont
entreposés plus de 4000 articles soit en
valeur
plus de 100 millions de francs
quatre-vingt dix ouvriers y travaillent
en permanence chaque année c'est plus de
10 mille tonnes de fournitures qui sont
envoyés soit par bateau soit par avion
dans les zones d'urgence en majorité du
matériel médical scolaire et de
l'outillage
pour l'ouganda nous avons un projet
d'urgence d'une valeur d'un million de
dollars qui est déjà en cours depuis
plusieurs mois nous avons envoyé déjà
sur place
des pièces de rechange pour réparer les
4000 pompe qui se trouve en milieu rural
des ponts d'eau potable vous savez
l'importance de l'eau potable
nous avons également envoyé un million
de doses d tétracycline qui sont des
doses contre une épidémie de choléra qui
règne dans le nord et dans le nord est
du pays pour l'aide alimentaire le
circuit est complètement différent pas
de stockage de vivres mais une politique
d'achats dans les pays limitrophes de la
zone secours
à vrai dire un faible pourcentage de
l'aide unicef plus axé sur des projets
dette à long terme
mais quelle que soit la forme de l'aide
un obstacle majeur subsiste
les secours ne peuvent pas revenir que
si préalablement les autorités locales
ont demandé l'aide des organismes
internationaux
le sénat français étaient réunis
aujourd'hui pour un débat de politique
étrangère le ministre monsieur jean
françois poncet a déclaré que la france
entendait rester maître de son langage
de ces initiatives et ses interlocuteurs
et puis bien sûr
au lendemain des déclarations de
monsieur giscard d'estaing sur
l'afghanistan et sur le proche orient
ces deux sujets ont été les thèmes des
orateurs danielle bray dans toutes les
interventions auxquelles monsieur jean
françois poncet répond ce moment même on
retrouve l exception de celle des
communistes le même sentiment
d'inquiétude centré sur l'invasion de
l'afghanistan par l'urss
monsieur marchi lacie a même reproché au
gouvernement de ne pas employer le mot
d'état de guerre pour sensibiliser les
français aux dangers de la situation
monsieur lecanu et le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères a une
fois de plus invité les socialistes à
soutenir la politique étrangère de la
france qui la preuve dans son ensemble
mais tout comme les orateurs du centre
de la gauche démocratique et du parti
socialiste
il regrette que l'action entreprise par
le président sadate en faveur de la paix
ne soit pas mieux soutenu par
l'entreprise
il souhaite aussi que la france fasse
comprendre qu'elle n'est pas
indifférente aux angoisses d'israël et
alors que monsieur garcia communistes
eux reprochent au gouvernement de ne pas
inviter officiellement monsieur yasser
arafat le leader de l olp
monsieur pontillon socialistes demandent
tous que monsieur à numéros centriste
pourquoi le président de la république
ne se rend pas en israël
monsieur pantillon a même ajouté à titre
personnel je cite créer un état
palestinien
circonscrit à la cisjordanie et à gaza
est aussi irréaliste que de demander à
la savoie d'absorber un million sept
cent mille réfugiés turbulent attaque en
règle de monsieur georges marchais ce
matin devant le comité central du parti
communiste français au lendemain de la
conférence de presse de monsieur giscard
d'estaing monsieur georges marchais a
dénoncé la politique brutale du pouvoir
et du patronat
la politique de la course aux armements
dans laquelle selon lui s'engage le
président de la république politique
qu'il considère comme pro atlantique
monsieur marché n'a pas non plus épargné
monsieur françois mitterrand
qu'il présente comme un allié de
monsieur giscard d'estaing françois
mitterrand est pourtant de monsieur
giscard d'estaing il le dit d'ailleurs
lui-même je le cite en france
tout ne va pas mal ainsi se manifestent
les convergences de plus en plus étroite
entre françois mitterrand et monsieur
giscard d'estaing par voie de
conséquence il s'est appliqué à fermer
soigneusement toutes les portes de
l'union le théâtre politico-militaire le
mouvement terroriste séparatiste basque
poursuit son action en espagne une
nouvelle bombe a explosé ce matin sur la
côte méditerranéenne de l'espagne sans
faire de blessé mais la sphère s'aggrave
car dans le même temps une organisation
d'extrême droite espagnole annonce qu'en
représailles
elle a posé des bombes au pays basque et
affirme que c'est elle qui a détruit le
syndicat d'initiative de biarritz pierre
bruneau halde
la question que se pose ce soir les
responsables espagnols du tourisme est
la suivante combien de temps les
vacanciers accepteront ils d'être pris
en sandwich entre les terroristes de
letea qui font sauter les hôtels ici à
javea près d'alicante et les terroristes
d'extrême droite qui ont décidé de
répliquer coup pour coup au pays basque
est aussi question subsidiaire combien
de temps les basques pour un style
défier le gouvernement espagnol au bord
des plages par explosif interposés sans
qu'il y ait de victimes chacun policiers
et terroristes se vante de prendre
toutes les précautions possibles pour
que ces engins ne s'aiment pas la mort
mais une bombe est une bombe
et l'an dernier les terroristes basques
ont tué cinq personnes par l'explosion
de l'une de ces bombes qui ne doivent
théoriquement jamais tu il avait prévenu
la police
les artificiers eux n'avaient pas eu le
temps d'arriver
oui dernière menace ce soir de letea où
on séparatistes base qui annonce qu'une
charge explosive explosera demain matin
à malaga 1 français entre dans le
gouvernement de l'église catholique le
vatican annonce la nomination en effet à
la tête du secrétariat au problème des
non croyants de monseigneur toupah
évêque auxiliaire de paris directeur de
l'institut catholique de paris
réquisitoire et plaidoiries aujourd'hui
aux proxys procès des proxénètes de
grenoble le procureur a réclamé des
peines de quatre à dix ans de prison
pour les proxénètes
le verdict pourrait être retardé à la
semaine prochaine de grenoble notre
envoyé spécial paul le faire dix ans
devant huit ans le jeune substitut
françois coste a demandé le maximum pour
les principaux inculpés de grenoble
jamais je n'ai vu placer si haut la
barre dans un dossier de ce genre il
faudra demain beaucoup de talent et de
conviction à la défense pour convaincre
les trois magistrats du tribunal
d'abaisser ce que j'appellerai les
seuils d'avenir de ces messieurs art
exutoire bien fait et c'était l'état est
un instrument terrible une sorte de
synthèse en forme de rouleau compresseur
reste imprimée à plat dans la mémoire
des juges des scènes des actes un mépris
violence qui n'est pas convenable de
raconter ici les seigneurs des chu des
quais de l'isère ne l'ont pas compris
tout à l'heure eux qui souriait parfois
peut-être pour conforter l'image qu'ils
racontent de même entre le soir la
prison peut être aussi pour conjurer la
pâte
iq qui transformé par moments leurs
sourires en rictus il y avait près
gendarmes dans le box à côté les
inculpés à défaut d'être le symbole
d'une justice apaisée
certains y ont vu le signe du mauvais
sort qui pèsent sur ce que le milieu
grenoblois appelé les jumeaux
casse-croûte la cour des comptes se
penchent chaque année sur la façon dont
les administrations les ministères les
communes gèrent leur budget elles
distribuent au passage aux mauvais
gestionnaires quelques coups de bâton
ainsi la cour des comptes préconise
cette année une réforme du fonds
national pour l'emploi
autre exemple ce sont les agriculteurs
dont les indignités reçu après les
intempéries excède largement leur revenu
imposable est un peu plus loin ce sont
les médecins qui utilisent largement
pour leur clientèle privée des
équipements publics
et puis quand on département des vosges
il vient de revendre 6 millions de
centimes un avion acheté plus de 100
millions de ces mêmes centimes quatre
ans seulement auparavant
voilà des hommes d'affaires
rassurez-vous la radio et la télé lyon
ne sont pas épargnés la cour des comptes
estime que son que leur régime financier
révèle les lacunes qui appelle d'une
révision danse quelles sanctions sont
prises éventuellement après de tels
rapports c'est la question qu'on est en
droit de se poser mais le secret le
fameux secret administratif empêche le
plus souvent de connaître la réponse
pourtant une loi a été votée en 1978
pour parvenir à une meilleure
transparence de l'administration mais
voter une loi est une chose l'appliquer
en étude une enquête de dominique torrès
sa ligne entre la législation la plus
libérale du monde celle des états unis
la loi de juillet 1978 sur l'accès aux
documents administratifs rend désormais
possible à toute personne en faisant la
demande de consulter sur place tout
document émanant du d'administration
d'un établissement public d'une
entreprise privée chargée de la gestion
d'un service public
en outre la loi prévoit qu'un
particulier puisse à présent avoir accès
à tous documents le concernant
personnellement les exceptions bien sûr
sont prévues notamment lorsqu'il s'agit
de la défense nationale de la sûreté de
l'état de procédures engagées devant les
tribunaux de secrets commerciaux ou doc
mon jugées confidentielles certes une
liste importante d'exception mais cette
voie ne bouleverse pas moi les rapports
entre administrés et administration
hier le secret ministre hâtif était la
règle aujourd'hui il devient l'exception
un organisme la cada a été créé à
matignon pour s'assurer de l'application
de cette loi
c'est à cette commission que le
particulier s'adresse d'éclat un litige
avec l'administration souvent corps et
qui sentent a dévoilé ses dossiers il
existe une commission la commission
d'accès aux documents administratifs qui
a pour mission de veiller à
l'application de la loi et les saisir
des difficultés rencontrées par les
administrés et elle doit donner un avis
dans un délai rapide c'est ce qu'elle
fait à ce jour elle a été saisie
d'environ 250 dossiers et la statue et
d'une manière favorable dans 90 % des
cas et je dois dire que l'administration
a elle même prétendu de la même manière
et dans la même proportion il existe je
le sais d administration qui ne veulent
pas admettre cette réforme et qui
veulent cultiver encore le secret
pourtant bien déçu et d'autres fois
c'est administration il faut les
dénoncer il appartient aux citoyens de
dire à la commission ce qui ne va pas et
je pense que très rapidement cette loi
entrera dans les moeurs
la loi sur l'accès aux documents
administratifs a dit faciliter votre
travail
et bien non pas du tout nous le pensions
nous avons beaucoup de réclamations de
la part d' d'abonnés au téléphone de la
part de consommateurs qui ont des
problèmes avec des notes trop élevé nous
sommes submergés le millier de demandes
de milliers de dossiers
nous pensions que l'information allait
passer mieux grâce à ces lois et ce
n'est pas du tout le cas les ptt ont
refusé d'appliquer ces lois alors nous
avons saisi la halle la cada composé
essentiellement de hauts fonctionnaires
nous concerne nous n'avions aucune
chance mais pas du tout la cada s'est
prononcée à l'unanimité du côté des
usagers en faveur des thèses que la
fuite des ford est à ce moment là nous
avons pensé que la partie était gagnée
et que vraiment l'administration des ptt
aurait les mains libres pour appliquer
ces lois sur la liberté d'accès aux
documents administratifs
il n'en est rien l'état a décidé que non
les ptt n'appliquerait pas ses lois on
est vraiment en train de passer à côté
d'une excellente
question de mieux traiter le
consommateur est d'améliorer les
relations difficiles entre l'usagé des
télécommunications d'un côté et la
grande et puissante et surpuissante
administration des ptt de l'autre côté
c'est très dommage si les enganes il
nous du mal à faire respecter la loi
pour les particuliers c'est encore plus
délicat quand je suis qui avait une loi
sur l'accès aux documents administratifs
je me suis dit bon on va y aller on va
essayer et jamais j'ai cru que ça se
passerait comme ça à l'environnement on
m'a dit que j'avais pas remplie le bon
formulaire à l'industrie on m'a dit que
le document n'était pas communicables à
l'agriculture on m'a fait un document
sur mesure on va dire que de toute façon
si on était obligé de donner le document
on peut toujours tort avoir d'honneur la
justice à matignon une atmosphère très
policier on a photocopié ma carte
d'identité on m'a gardé pendant trois
heures dans une guérite et finalement
pour vous dire que le document n'était
pas là bref j'ai pas une chance sur les
150 documents que j'ai avec là mais je
ne suis tombé que sur les exceptions
écouter la personne qui s'occupe du oui
alors si vous voulez est pas possible de
venir sur place consulter les deux si
éventuellement pourquoi venir consulter
des dossiers seul appareil et je suis je
suis un particulier
ah ben oui mais madame on consulte pas
des dossiers comme ici ce n'est pas un
bureau de renseignements c'est un
mystère
puis il est vous voulez consulter des
dossiers titre personnel d'abord il
faudrait savoir pourquoi le dossier
n'existe pas il n'est pas accessible au
grand public
l'afer est en cours la personne
compétente est absente
il faut revenir téléphoner écrire c'est
jamais nom lester un flou artistique
dessinée probablement à décourager les
curieux
en outre deux ans après le vote de la
loi les documents n'ont toujours pas été
signalisés un peu si pour le particulier
de savoir sous quelle forme
le document doit être demandée
impossible même de savoir s'il existe en
plus la tendance n'a pas suivi ni le
local ni le personnel compétent n'ont
été mis en place mais surtout la loi à
l'accès aux documents administratifs
bouleverse les habitudes des
fonctionnaires pour eux c'est encore un
crime de lèse majesté que de communiquer
aux simples particuliers des documents
officiels
visiblement l'air des ronds de cuir
n'est pas encore terminée cette enquête
si elle vous intéresse parce qu'elle
concerne notre vie au quotidien
bull annonce se poursuivra la semaine
prochaine dans le magazine c'est la vie
à 18h30 chaque soir sur antenne 2
premiers départs en vacances aujourd'hui
des départs qui vont heureusement
s'étaler jusqu'à mardi 1er juillet bison
futé conseille aux automobilistes
résidant au nord de la ligne
bordeaux-grenoble de ne pas partir entre
3 heures et 9 heures du matin les samedi
28 août à lire demain dimanche 29 juin
et mardi 1er juillet il recommande
également d'utiliser les itinéraires bis
qui sont en place et itinéraires de
remplacement
je ne voudrais pas vous donner de faux
joie mais le prix de l'essence oui j'ai
bien dit le prix de l'essence risquent
de baisser dans certaines grandes
surfaces qui peuvent désormais importer
librement des produits pétroliers en
tout cas edouard leclerc le pdg des
magasins qui porte son nom est bien
décidé lui à casser les prix des
carburants à coup de rabais
jusqu'où peut-il aller et pourquoi les
compagnies pétrolières ne font-elles pas
autant une enquête de jean claude
renoult depuis mercredi six grandes
surfaces ont l'autorisation d'importer
directement des produits pétroliers en
les achetant aux pays producteurs ou
encore sur le marché libre de rotterdam
en s'approvisionnant ainsi directement
elle compte bien exploiter à fond un
arrêté de 1974 qui autorise des rabais
sur le super et les sens jusqu'à 10
centimes par litre
je ferai tout ce que je pourrai pour
alléger le prix de l'essence qui est
devenu trop lourd dans les budgets des
ménages
est-ce que vous irez jusqu'avant de
l'essence au prix coûtant et je crois
que nous n'avons pas besoin de vendre à
prix coûtant les centres coeur travail à
l'image extrêmement réduite et nous ne
devons pas nous détruire toutes les
copies sont dépendants qui n'ont pas les
mêmes possibilités que nous nous devons
travailler avec une marche normale mais
sans pour cela faire 5 milliard de
nouveaux francs de bénéfices comme elf
et rap
les compagnies pétrolières elles avec
leurs réseaux de stations-service n'ont
jamais consenti de tels rabais
nous avons des frais plus élevés que
monsieur leclerc les grandes surfaces
disent les pétroliers et nous
continuerons à pratiquer des prix
uniformes des distributeurs pur
d'ailleurs quand kelly le travail dans
les grandes surfaces peuvent faire des
rabais même à prix d'achat égal plus
important que le négoce traditionnel
parce qu'ils ont de moindres coûts de
distribution
il faut bien voir que les dégâts ce
traditionnel est indispensable lui aussi
l'alimentation du consommateur français
car le consommateur français ne pourrait
pas vivre avec les seules grandes
surfaces vous réclamez déjà depuis un
certain temps la liberté des prix en
matière de produits pétroliers notamment
de carburant auto c'est pour pouvoir
accorder des rabais
nous demandons la liberté des prix pour
pouvoir assurer l'approvisionnement du
marché et servir le consommateur en
toutes circonstances lorsqu'ils
marchaient étendu dans l'ensemble du
monde est également quand
malheureusement il est déprimé mais nous
n'y pouvons rien c'est la seule façon
d'adapter les quantités approvisionner
aux nécessités du marché en cas de
tensions du marché pétrolier de
difficultés d'approvisionnement il n'est
pas sûr que les grandes surfaces pour
maintenir leur rabais ce qui est certain
aujourd'hui c'est que les automobilistes
peuvent un peu plus qu'avant
quel jouer la concurrence
incident entre agriculteurs et policiers
devant la préfecture de rennes cet après
midi les agriculteurs venus de tous les
coins des côtes du nord ont arraché les
grilles de la préfecture avec leurs
prêteurs d'ailleurs s'en sont suivis
avec les forces de l'ordre les
agriculteurs ont déversé plusieurs
centaines de tonnes de pommes de terre
par terre afin de protester contre la
mévente de leurs productions en ce
moment sport hinault n'aura pas garder
très longtemps son maillot jaune au
terme des deux demi étapes d'aujourd'hui
en allemagne il s'est fait ravir la
première place par le land est nettement
christine par la victoire de la
formation khaled a permis à geri
knetemann de prendre le maillot jaune
dans ce contre la montre par équipe de
45 km 800 wiesbaden francfort ce matin
le premier tronçon francfort wiesbaden a
vu la victoire du néerlandais race
hinault possédait encore le maillot
jaune net man ici en tête je te mêles
que vandevenne race banvit ont réalisé
le meilleur temps du circuit 53 minutes
45 secondes et 52 la formation gagnante
ont reçu 2 minutes 15 de bonification à
reporter au classement individuel
le néerlandais knetemann nouveau leader
du tour
les renault gitane avec leur chef de
file bernard hinault se sont
remarquablement battus bernard hinault
n'hésitant pas à effectuer de nombreux
relais l'équipe termine 2e 45 secondes
des râles elle à cause de la
bonification hinault a perdu son maillot
jaune le deuxième du classement général
et les néerlandais race hinault est
troisième à 20 secondes du leader
tout e mail est quatrième
wimbledon le paraguay un victor pesci
s'est qualifié pour le troisième tour en
battant cet après-midi le
tchécoslovaquie and co des champs trois
sets la météo
pour terminer je n'ai pas de très bonnes
nouvelles à vous donner
d'abord les températures d'aujourd'hui
pas brillant pour la saison demain matin
les pluies se déverseront sur la vendée
la bretagne et la normandie ailleurs le
ciel souvent nuageux aura tout de même
connaîtra tout de même quelques
éclaircies dans l'est et le sud est en
cours de journée le ciel se couvrira sur
toutes les régions
personne n'est épargné avec des pluies
intermittentes surtout dans la moitié
nord près des côtes de la manche et de
l'atlantique il y aura des vents à ses
fins ce journal est terminée le dernier
rendez vous avec l'information ce soir
par la marée puis demain samedi et demi
et présenté par jean claude mongeau et
georges bégoux sera consacré aux fêtes
de molière en direct de pézenas bonsoir
excellente soirée sur antenne 2 au
revoir